[Música]
a ivete divide em três etapas falar do
passado do presente e do futuro tá é uma
pergunta o que todo mundo que têm em
comum todos somam saber se a única coisa
que a gente tem em comum com corda tem
um livro muito legal que eu recomendo
que a a breve história da humanidade
esse é o quadro introdutório do do livro
que ele faz um overview da evolução do
homem ao longo da história o homem
existe homo sapiens há 200 mil anos né é
o homem só existe há 200 mil anos o
universo existe a 4.5 bilhões de anos a
gente eu vou começar a contar a história
do homem a partir da agricultura que a
gente está falando de 12 mil anos a
agricultura só existe há 12 mil anos
o processo de cultivar e planejar o
cultivo identificar as mudanças
climáticas que acontecem todos os anos
só começou de 12 mil anos pra cá e isso
permitiu que o início das primeiras
aldeias
as pessoas pararam de ser nome de
caçadores e coletores e passaram a se
estabelecer um local fixo e cada vez
mais as relações humanas foram se
intensificando e pode haver a troca de
conhecimento
isso aconteceu de uma forma centralizada
na humanidade no planeta terra em
períodos temporais diferentes onde essas
pessoas não tiveram contatos com uma com
alguma com as outras não foi uma um lado
que ensinou o outro foi uma consciência
coletiva que trouxe agricultura em
diferentes momentos depois da escrita
que permitiu que o conhecimento fosse
passado não somente pela oratória não
somente pelo contato eu com vocês
através dos livros manuscritos era
escrito uma vez e dezenas centenas
milhares de pessoas poderiam ler aquele
conteúdo isso impulsionou a a
transmissão do conhecimento ea
multiplicação de 10
aí depois muita gente estava produzindo
etapa tendo sobra e muita gente
escrevendo como produzir
pior como fazer poesia como se fazer
arte e não estava fácil fazer esse fluxo
de valor não se criaram as moedas onde
facilitou muito o transporte logístico
das coisas
não precisava carregar um saco pra cá um
saco pra lá era uma moeda no saco isso
facilitou muito
depois vieram as grandes cidades grandes
impérios esse mapa é de 323 de cristo
que mostra como os impérios eram criados
estava lá no meio do do oriente médio
que a gente conhece como hoje era quem
mandava no mundo
depois as religiões se tornar
instituições de controle e começaram a
controlar tanto a igreja copta cristã
enquanto islã contra outras religiões
pelo mundo
só que fizeram muita coisa errada
divulgavam as coisas boas da religião
mas controlavam criaram index de livros
proibidos tentaram controlar o
conhecimento mas eles fizeram muitas
coisas boas
eles incentivaram as grandes navegações
já pararam para imaginar o tanto que um
cara que fala que vai entrar no barco
sair mar afora há 600 anos atrás seria
taxado da mesma forma que a gente julga
hoje os caras que estão querendo pra
marte de loucos
esses caras foram longos eles não sabem
o que é do outro lado eles largaram suas
famílias seus negócios seus trabalhos
alguns eram prisioneiros e viram uma
oportunidade de reconstruir a vida pra
fazer é descobrir um novo mundo
aí vem esse pessoal aqui e tumultuou
tudo isso questionou tudo falou que não
a terra não é o centro do universo é o
sol não existem as leis da do movimento
dos astros
tudo coordenado teve outro que foi lá e
criou a três leis de newton entendeu a
mecânica das lutas dos movimentos a
inventar a imprensa
o livro era poderoso a imprensa dá um
outro está outro outro salto porque
qualquer conhecimento pode ser produzido
hoje e amanhã
dezenas de milhares de pessoas poderiam
ter acesso a um centavo de dólar
comprando o jornal fizeram a revolução
industrial que teve suas coisas boas em
suas coisas ruins mas é a melhor coisa
que as revoluções
será outro pra gente foi a primeira vez
de forma sistêmica fosse possível uma
uma movimentações de classes sociais
antes quem tinha dinheiro era quem tinha
terra era aristocracia e agora permitiu
que a burguesia pudesse começar a ganhar
dinheiro e se movimentar o
empreendedorismo que a gente fala hoje
começou lá atrás mas as pessoas que
pegaram as tecnologias e questionaram e
puderam se movimentar e trazer empregos
e tirar as pessoas do campo hamas tinha
problema claro que tinha tudo isso que
eu falei foi feito somente em 2000 anos
a gente tem 200 mil anos de história
isso tudo foi feito em 200 mil anos em
2000 anos que aconteceu nos últimos 200
anos reduzir essa janela de tempo
o jovem tesla criou a corrente alternada
que permitiu que a gente está aqui
usando ford evento a linha de produção
no de carros permitiu que o carro
deixasse de ser o customizador pudesse
ser acessível para qualquer americano
inventar o telégrafo te levo do telefone
que permitiu que as distâncias perdesse
o sentido comunicação não precisa mais
esperar
ela pode ser instantânea de um pra um
qualquer momento
logo foi lá falou que levou a a e teve
outros dois loucos lá que inventar uma
turbina de avião e puderam reduzir agora
não só a distância da voz da comunicação
mas a distância física das pessoas é
possível sair de um ponto a outro ponto
em questão de horas você chega inventar
a locomotiva a vapor onde não é mais
necessário os cavalos para transportar
carga
você pode ter a atravessar continente
através de uma máquina começará a se
discutir a igualdade das raças em 88 foi
a foi feita a abolição da escravatura da
escravidão no brasil a gente fala mas
foi muito tarde a mas não sei o que
gente
o brasil só tem 500 anos de história a
gente não tá falando da europa que tem
10 mil anos 15 mil anos o brasil só tem
500 que aconteceu nos últimos 100 anos
a telefonia se tornou acessível
tudo bem antes eu tinha que tá no
imposto de renda
une tudo mas hoje em dia podemos
questionar esse jovem inventor beneficie
lina e com isso as mortes cada vez foram
mais premeditados e controladas
a gente começou a a poder usufruir do
consumo
qualquer pessoa pode comprar qualquer
coisa ah mas existe indústria que
manipula tudo tem isso tudo mas hoje
qualquer coisa pode ser comprada de
maior ou menor qualidade mas pode só
queria também fez coisa feia em três
guerras gente matou muita gente a gente
criou extremismos
a gente faz o que é um poderia ser
melhor do que outro
se no final das contas todos somos
humanos ainda convivemos a capacidade de
pegar uma invenção científica genial de
einstein transformar numa bomba nuclear
e matar um monte de gente mas a guerra
acabou e e aquele e agora né
acho que o melhor resultado da guerra
foi levar o homem à lua porque a corrida
espacial fomentou uma necessidade de ser
o primeiro na exploração espacial e
conseguiu fazer aquilo que os grandes
navegadores fizeram e 1400 1500 quer
quebrar fronteiras daquilo que a gente
achava que era quebrável que aconteceu
nos últimos 50 anos a lei de moore
alguém já ouviu falar disso demorou fala
é um memorando um papa da computação ele
identificou um padrão onde o a
capacidade de processamento de um
semicondutor duplica a cada 18 meses
enquanto seu custo de 20 pela metade
isso cria uma curva exponencial
logaritmo aí vem um jovem chamado carlo
foi meu professor sensacional que ele
pegou isso criou a teoria das mudanças
aceleradas que ele identificou um padrão
ele nos mostra os futuristas que existem
hoje viu está é ele e ele acerta os anos
que as coisas vão acontecer bem surreal
é quase tudo que tem tecnologia aplicada
também evoluir nessa mesma velocidade
nessa mesma redução de custo
moral da história tudo que eu falei até
agora é a parte horizontal do gráfico
a parte que fica reta são os últimos 50
anos
cada pontinho aí é uma das grandes
inovações que mudaram o mundo
hoje todo mundo tem internet alguém que
consegue ficar um dia sem acesso à
internet
olha a velocidade do celular mudou a
cara pra pensar qual celular vocês
tinham há cinco anos atrás
há dez anos atrás hoje em 36 horas você
pode estar em qualquer lugar do mundo
onde um avião atravessa o mundo e 36
horas ou mais se viu com as piores
conexões que você tiver 36 horas está do
outro lado do mundo que aconteceu nos
últimos 10 anos que têm celular
levanta a mão quem é que não tem celular
alguém decide não ter um celular hoje
vocês sabiam que o a capacidade de
processamento que existe dentro de um
celular é a mesma capacidade de
processamento computacional da polo que
levou o homem à lua
vocês têm uma nave espacial dentro do
celular de vocês
essa é a capacidade de processamento que
cada celular de vocês têm
você tem um celular um tablet e notebook
computador do trabalho computador em
casa um computador no carro por aí né
quem é que o timbu ninguém levantar
nossa hora né
vocês já pararam para pensar o tanto que
o tinga e outros aplicativos de
relacionamento tão permitindo que
pessoas se conheçam de uma forma que
nunca antes aconteceu porque você não
cruzaria com essas pessoas na faculdade
no ponto de ônibus na balada na família
são pessoas totalmente fora do seu
círculo que você não se interessaria de
primeira mas que você abra se permite
conversar conhecer trocar ideia é a
pensar como é que vai à miscigenação
cultural e vão seus filhos dessas
pessoas
rubber que nunca usou ver oq simus
rubber quebrou o mercado dos táxis que
era uma hegemonia e por outro lado as
cpus e os resultados da indústria
automobilística as vendas de carro
aumentaram 30 por cento no último
trimestre por causa das locadoras de
veículos localiza e outras contra no
caso pedro beber tela quente e fala da
empresa americana cai a ter tudo que
esse maluco do almoço que faz tem que
ser acompanhado
ele faz carros elétricos que custam o
dobro concorrentes e paga o dobro o
dobro do preço
só que ele não tem uma garantia não tem
garantia eterna você nunca tem que
trocar o óleo ele vai de 0 a 100 em três
segundos igual a ferrari vai
ele é lindo maravilhoso confortável ele
estraga
você paga o dobro né pra não ter que
levar o mecânico
ele fala que as únicas coisas que têm
trocado tese é é a maçaneta e o pneu por
desgaste interrupção o resto não estraga
tem que passar o lubrificante em
combustão seb é modelo o mercado
hoteleiro remodelou o mercado de
habitação e mais legal ele pro ele faz
uma distribuição de renda que não era um
propósito dele mas hoje 10% de lucro que
vai para uma rede hoteleira esse lucro é
com os 90 por cento vai para aquela
pessoa que alugou o quarto extra na casa
dela no bbb só fica com 10% de lucro
esse dinheiro não está subindo e já está
sendo centralizada
então sim tem como fazer a distribuição
de renda sim tem como ganhar dinheiro
ajudando o próximo
em outra bela moça que
junto com o verde eo a empresa do da
amazon e do da verde exploração espacial
que começou isto de novo e vai ser a
grande fronteira do de negócios entre os
10 15 anos até até 2030 que a missão de
votar num homem marte
parece loucura né mas não é realidade
todas as empresas podem ficar aqui até
amanhã citando casos são empresas que
começaram desde uma startup ou uma
spin-off dentro de uma grande indústria
ou um projeto uma faculdade que teve um
apoio e foi pra fora da universidade e
em histórias
só que foram todos que viram dentro do
caos que a gente vive hoje dentro da
desigualdade que a gente vive hoje um
dos problemas que a gente tem hoje uma
oportunidade de fazer algo diferente
sair questionar o ta o paradigma que a
gente tem hoje
e assim este é o uberaba visitar algumas
das empresas que estão na área de agro
cruzamento é da engenharia genética
avançada com a aam o controle da do gado
para a gente para identificar potência
potenciais bactérias que podem fazer mal
ao gado identificar quantos e como uma
salsicha
você sabe que o animal está lá dentro
fizeram uma pesquisa uma vez uma moça já
eram 10 com 5% de dna humano dentro da
salsicha absurdo número de cinema ou
morrer alguém processado ou é muita
falta de higiene
então os dois têm problemas essa empresa
ela faz o sequenciamento genético do
produto da indústria alimentícia para
votar na embalagem aquilo que você está
comendo
essa é uma é uma fintech que ela faz
antecipação antecipação de caixa que o
pequeno produtor
ele entrega a mercadoria antes de
entregar a mercadoria ele já recebe o
dinheiro
a gente sabe o quanto o fluxo de caixa
que era muito empresa então criar uma
forma de a facilitar esse processo
essa faz controle biológico através da
identificação de ida de colocar a praga
de controle biológico somente na área
que precisa dentro de um pomar
principalmente unidos
essa é pra mim uma das mais sensacional
eles criaram um produto que é uma
embalagem de 400 ml que tem gosto de
toddynho que tem todos os nutrientes
necessários para a alimentação diária de
um ser humano é gostoso
sei que tenho minhas dúvidas mas é
saudável e está sendo vendido a um dólar
tirando várias pessoas da zona de
subnutrição um mundo moral da história o
mundo está mudando muito mudando muito
rápido muito rápido e para melhor
é claro que tem problema assim eu
reclame seu reforço muito
veja o problema como uma oportunidade dá
pra ganhar dinheiro ajudando o próximo
o homem teve mais expectativa de vida no
mundo só aumenta a expectativa de de
vida desde o nascimento na mortalidade
infantil diminui e aumenta a mortalidade
infantil diminui a quantidade de pessoas
que morreram por causa do conflito
armado desde a primeira à segunda guerra
depois a quantidade o motivo das mortes
grande maioria são problemas cardíacos
respiratórios e câncer
são todos problemas que a gente consegue
resolver através da prevenção
a gente tem energia limpa e computadores
acessíveis
o custo da banda de internet só diminuiu
o custo de armazenamento de dados só
diminuiu o custo da bateria só diminuiu
o preço por watt através de energia
solar só diminuiu em condições melhores
de trabalho e educação
a quantidade de anos que uma pessoa
estuda só aumenta a quantidade de
pessoas alfabetizadas no mundo só
aumenta a quantidade de pessoas com
estudo além dos do ensino básico que
estudam além fazer mestrado doutorado e
cento só aumentou ea curva a tendência
cada vez
aumente mais o trabalho infantil
diminuir a quantidade de horas
trabalhadas por pessoa por dia diminui a
fome ea pobreza estão diminuindo a
quantidade a percentual do que você
gosta do seu salário com comida tá
diminuindo a quantidade de pessoas
vivendo abaixo da linha da pobreza tais
diminuindo novas formas humano
relações humanas e sociais agora são
cotidianos
esse é um gráfico que não não dá pra
entender muito mais eu gosto de mostrar
a linha verde à linha verde mostra todos
os casais hetero e homossexuais que se
conheceram online estão hoje casados há
coisas que não aconteceram antes
quantidade de pessoas que vivem em
regimes democráticos é o verde aumentou
no futuro
você está preparado no futuro você
consegue imaginar o que vai ser futuro
a dica que eu dou e desliga a tv vai
estudar a imprensa é muito focada no
factóide naquilo que vem de hoje
o que vende é a desgraça o que vende a
dor
amorim falou muito bem todo sofrimento é
válido a gente tem que foi bom pra gente
a gente tem que focar no que é bom para
o próximo ea tv só fala coisa ruim
ela só repete os arquétipos na tv na
novela de coisas ruins porque é isso que
vende não desliga a tv
desliga o factóide vai lê vai estudar
vai ensinar a ensinar dando aula na
escola é vim aqui dividir compartilhar a
comunidade educação muda tudo a educação
ela não é aquela educação tradicional
educação tradicional necessária a
educação através da comunidade o que
muda é o que vai poder mudar a nossa
existência
a gente se aproximar das pessoas a gente
queria fazer o bem ao próximo
a gente ensina a quem não sabe é poder
conectar pessoas à comunidade ea
educação são as únicas formas de
transformar o mundo melhor a condição
que a gente tem hoje é é só vai mudar se
a gente parar de reclamar parar de botar
a culpa nos outros e fazer alguma coisa
diferente é muito cômodo com um governo
mas furar a fila para pegar o ônibus
muito é muito comum eu então a gente tem
que dar o primeiro passo a gente ensina
através do exemplo a gente ensina
através da elucidação de um mundo melhor
os recursos existem eles são abundantes
tem tecnologia você com uma ideia boa
você tem acesso a dinheiro sim tem fundo
vindo pra cá tem a bmg finep vai
acreditando dinheiro sobrando que sobra
dinheiro que não têm
boa pessoas existem vontade de um mundo
melhor vocês estarem aqui no sábado à
tarde prova disso
vocês acreditam no mundo melhor com os
recursos e as pessoas ea tecnologia
existe o futuro já está aqui essa frase
acho sensacional
ele está muito mal distribuído como é
que a gente distribui igualmente como é
que todo mundo pode ter o conforto que a
gente está tendo aqui com um
privilegiado com quem faz isso como é
que quer seu futuro
[Aplausos]